there was a video it was trending all
over the internet yesterday and it had
to do with twerking
now you know what twerking is it's when
you in a sort of cartoonish way
caricature the
physical aspects of sex and this is
passed off for dancing now and so it's
it's
very grotesque i mean i'm not saying i'm
i'm horrified or offended by it i
i'm it's just grotesque because it's uh
not something one would like to see it's
not particularly beautiful not graceful
uh not edifying and not dignified and
there was a business owner who came in
and he's a black business owner and he
was calling out the black
community generally and he said when
people come in and they maybe they drink
too much and they start twerking
this is degraded behavior and he's not
going to tolerate it
i invested a lot of money into buying
this building into developing this
concept
so black people can have somewhere nice
to go to okay somewhere where we can
feel good about ourselves as a
there's one stop to music please
somewhere where our people can feel good
about ourselves as a culture okay
no no real talk and so all this twerking
is taking the prime
take it to pink don't bring it here
because we're a restaurant and so beyond
that
75 of our customers are ladies and i'm
not mean to show respect for themselves
for how they carry themselves here so
how can i tell the men to respect
themselves
and you guys are talking on last year if
you want to do it you out my restaurant
because i did it for our people and i
did it for our culture so don't do it
now don't do it again i don't want to
hear it if you don't like it
get out because i don't need your money
i need to provide something for my
people
don't do it again thank you
that guy's absolutely right he he lost
his temper and he said a word he
probably shouldn't have he
undercut his point a little bit because
he said be respectful of people be
respectful of women then he you know
gets a little carried away but the point
he's making is totally right
do not do that and this is a big divide
here
you've got basically the entire left on
the side of yeah twerk twerking's
empowering
degrade your body treat yourself as just
a physical
meat puppet do whatever you pursue your
appetites do it
that's empowering right that's the left
tells you that even the libertarian
right
often tells you that you'll you'll hear
people on the libertarian rights say
that
sort of degraded behaviors or drag queen
story hour
are actually blessings of liberty to
invoke a phrase from our founding
fathers all of whom would have been
horrified at twerking and would have
almost certainly
applauded that business owner for saying
what he said you see that
that kind of is one side of the divide
then you have conservatives on the other
saying no just don't do that we need to
have standards and i think
this is something that conservatives
have gotten wrong particularly
in the realm of political correctness
for a long time but it's something
they've gotten wrong at trying to fight
the left since the cultural revolutions
of the 1960s
all the way up to the present which is
that the right has taken the bait
the left came in and upended all of the
old standards conservatives used to have
standards
i know we like to pretend that we didn't
in the past but joe mccarthy was not a
liberal okay the
the house un-american activities
committee
was not liberal the haze code that that
governed hollywood
and and did in a way censor hollywood
but it gave us some of the greatest
movies ever made
uh that was conservative that wasn't
liberal
and what i think the left has convinced
conservatives of in the past
50 years is that actually we shouldn't
have any standards
that if you're a real conservative then
you want people to do whatever they want
you're for pure freedom and a very
degraded understanding of what that
freedom is
yeah twerking that's totally
conservative yeah vulgarity and
obscenity everywhere
and you know all sorts of disordered
relationships and all that's totally
conservative it's not it's not it's not
a blessing of liberty
it's uh not conducive to human
flourishing every society has standards
we should have standards too i totally
applaud that restaurant owner
for for doing his part to try to fix the
culture a little bit
and actually having some confidence to
articulate a standard and i think a lot
of conservatives should pay attention
to what he's saying we've been making
this mistake
on the right with regard to how we
approach the new standards of the left
we used to have ballroom dancing now we
have twerking
the conservative perspective would be
that the waltzing is better than the
twerking
the more hands up laissez-faire
perspective that conservatives have been
deceived into embracing is that oh who
cares you do you you wanna one
guy wants to wall room dance one guy
wants to twerk it's kind of the same
thing
it's you can just do whatever you want
no i don't think so
you